g is a function that describes an
arithmetic sequence here are the first
few terms of the sequence so they say
the first term is four second term is
three and four-fifths third term is
three and three-fifths fourth term is
three and two-fifths find the values of
the missing parameters a and b in the
following recursive definition of the
sequence
so they say the nth term is going to be
equal to a if n is equal to 1 and it's
going to be equal to
g of n minus 1
plus b if n is greater than 1. and so i
encourage you to pause this video and
see if you can figure out what a and b
are going to be
well the first one to figure out a is is
actually pretty straightforward if n is
equal to one if n is equal to one the
first term when n equals one is four so
a is equal to four so we could write
this as g of n
is equal to 4
if
n
is equal to 1.
and now let's think about the second
line the second line is interesting it's
saying it's going to be equal to the
previous term g of n minus 1. this is
this means the n minus 1 term plus b
will give you the nth term
let's just think about what's happening
with this arithmetic sequence when i go
from the first term to the second term
what have i done i have looks like i've
subtracted one-fifth so minus one-fifth
and then it's an arithmetic sequence so
i should subtract or add the same amount
every time and i am i'm subtracting
one-fifth and so i am subtracting
one-fifth
and so one way to think about it if we
were to go the other way we could say
for example that g
of 4
is equal to g
of 3
minus one-fifth
minus
one-fifth you see that right over here g
of three is this you subtract one-fifth
you get g of four you see that right
over there and of course i could have
written this like g of 4 is equal to g
of 4 minus 1
minus 1 5. so when you look at it this
way you could see that if i'm trying to
find the nth term it's going to be the n
minus 1 term
plus negative one-fifth so b is negative
one-fifth once again if i'm trying to
find the fourth term if n is equal to
four
i'm not going to use this first case
because this has to be
for n equals one so if n equals four i
would use the second case so then it
would be g of four minus one it would be
g of three minus one fifth and so we
could say g of n is equal to
g of
n minus one so the term right before
that
minus one-fifth
if
n is greater than one but for the sake
of this problem
we see
we see that a
is equal to four
and b
is equal to negative one-fifth